yes the BBC director General Tim Davey
has just spoken to the BBC he said he
will not resign over the handling of the
Gary lineker Saga and he has said he
hopes to form a resolution still with
the match of the day presenter to screen
you the words he's said he has said I'm
sorry audiences have been affected and
they haven't got the programming this is
a reference to uh football focus and
match the day football folks being off
there and match the day being disrupted
and what Tim Davey says is as a keen
sports fan I know to miss programming is
a real blow and I'm sorry about that we
are working very hard to resolve this
situation and make sure we get output on
air he said everyone wants to calmly
resolve the situation Gary lineker's the
best in the business that's not for
debate but no indication there from Tim
Davey how he hopes to resolve the
situation it was Tim Davey we would
imagine was involved in the
decision-making process that led to Gary
lineker being taken off the air then
announcement yesterday that Gary linear
could not be presenting match of the day
tonight we are led to understand that
Max today will now only the last 20
minutes rather than one hour and 20
minutes tonight on BBC One but these are
the first words from Tim Davey today
since Gary lineker was taken off the air
since various other members the BBC
staff revolted and said they would not
appear on air if Gary lineker was being
taken off the air the fact we had Alex
Scott the Football Focus presenter
saying she wouldn't present that program
also on radio we had Mark Chapman saying
he wouldn't present five live sports
which was due to go on air at 12 o'clock
and tonight's match of the day will be a
very different show there'll be no
pundits there'll be no Studio guests
there'll be no presenter and we imagine
no commentators because the commentators
said they wouldn't take part in the show
but
as it stands now what Tim Davey is
calling a difficult day for the BBC and
hoping that there is a resolution they
hope to resolve the situation he says he
hopes to resolve this resolve the
situation calmly and certainly an
indication from Tim Davey he wants to
try to keep Gary lineker but one thing
hearing from Gary lineker side is
perhaps I'm surprised that Tim Davey the
Direct General is still in Washington DC
rather than actually back in the UK